ça fait longtemps que le mois du
documentaire existe c'est une
manifestation nationale qui met en avant
les films de documentaires
nous attendons un petit peu
cet événement ce le mois de novembre
pour mettre en valeur les films
documentaires donc là on a pas mal de
film en stock au grenier à sel vous
découvrirez pour les soldats tombés qui
est un documentaire réalisé par peter
jackson donc le réalisateur du seigneur
des anneaux du hobbit
il a mis aux couleurs il a sonorisé des
images d'archivés de 14 18 de l'armée
anglaise c'est phénoménal
à découvrir sur grand écran je vous
propose aussi le documentaire course
là-bas
nous sommes donc à alep en syrie et ça
va être établie qui vient de naître et
sa maman
vie le siège au jour le jour et film
tout ce qui se passe avec son aîné et à
l'hôpital où elle travaille découvrez
donc pour sabah et pour les soldats
tombés cette semaine au cinéma le
grenier à sel
[Musique]